>> Tucker: IT IS NOT HARD PRAY
TO CHARLIE, STAY WITH US FOR A
SECOND.
TO THE PRESIDENT IF YOU WERE
LISTENING BROUGHT UP MS-13 IN
AMERICA, HERE IS SAID.
>> JUST TWO DAYS AGO OUR
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE CHARGED 22
MEMBERS OF THE SAVAGE, BRUTAL,
HORRIBLE GANG MS-13 IN
CALIFORNIA.
[APPLAUSE]
WHO HAVE BEEN VIOLENTLY
OPERATING FOR TEN YEARS.
WE GOT THEM ALL, WE THINK THAT
THEY ARE NO GOOD.
WITH CONDUCTING BRUTAL MEDIEVAL
STYLE KILLINGS.
DO YOU KNOW WHAT TO MEDIEVAL
STYLE IS?
>> Tucker: CHARGING 22 MS-13 MS-
>> Tucker: CHARGING 22 MS-13 MS3
AGENTS WITH MURDERS.
BREAKING NEWS CHIEF
CORRESPONDENT TRACE GALLAGHER
HAS MORE ON THAT TONIGHT.
>> CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN FIGHTING
TO KEEP SANCTUARY CITIES AND
FIGHTING AGAINST THE TRUMP
IMMIGRATION POLICY.
THEY SAY 22 MS-13 MEMBERS, 19 AS
YOU SAY IN THE COUNTRY
ILLEGALLY, SYSTEMATICALLY AND
BRUTALLY KILLED AT LEAST SEVEN
PEOPLE USING AS THE PRESIDENT
SAID MEDIEVAL STYLE KILLING
TECHNIQUES THAT FEDERAL
LAW ENFORCEMENT HAS NOT SEEN IN
TWO DECADES.
LISTEN TO THIS.
>> ONE OF THE DEFENDANTS
ALLEGEDLY CARVED OUT HIS HEART
BEFORE THROWING THE BODY PARTS
INTO A CANYON.
>> ONE VICTIM WAS KILLED FOR
CROSSING OUT MS-13 GRAFFITI,
ANOTHER WAS A HOMELESS MAN WHO
MADE THE FATAL MISTAKE OF
FALLING ASLEEP IN A PARK THAT
MS-13 CONSIDERS ITS GANG TURF.
THE 22 GANG MEMBERS ARRESTED ARE
ALSO THOUGHT TO BE RESPONSIBLE.
HUNDREDS OF OTHER CRIMES IN
SEVERAL OTHER STATES.
WE SHOULD NOTE THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION IS TRYING TO
ADDRESS THE CRISIS AT THE BORDER
BY MAKING REQUIREMENTS TO APPLY
FOR ASYLUM STRICTER.
NANCY PELOSI SAYS THAT IS CRUEL
AND UNUSUAL.
SHE IS TALKING ABOUT THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION, BUT WE SHOULD
MENTION THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION'S AT THE SAME.
LISTEN TO THIS.
>> TYPICALLY REFUGEES ARE NOT
GRANTED JUST BASED ON ECONOMIC
NEEDS OR BECAUSE A FAMILY LIVES
IN A BAD NEIGHBORHOOD OR
POVERTY, BUT SPECIFICALLY
DEFINED.